hey since fans your friendly
neighborhood narrator here Jeremy with a
special message I you tuber have written
a book back it up back it up I know
shocking
now before you immediately X out of this
page and go back to reading TMZ let me
assure you it's not a typical youtuber
book it's not a cookbook it's not a
memoir a ghost written biography or some
rushed of collection of comical taunts
on movies this is a real book a book
book one hundred and thirty seven
thousand nine hundred twenty-five words
and thirty three chapters of full-on
fictional events born out of my warped
brain and it goes on pre-order today now
everyone who pre-orders the book and
then sends us their order confirmation
number will be added to a mailing list
and those folks on that list will get
some cool stuff namely access to
unreleased sins videos at least one
maybe even two if I have time okay okay
you talked me into it I'll do two full
regular sins videos that we will never
release to the public only those on the
book pre-order mailing list will ever
see them in addition there will be other
fun updates and videos from me along the
way
sneak peeks at videos that we will later
release to the public and even some
random acts of kindness from me to you I
think now if you're still interested
here's a little bit about the book so
the Able's is about a group of superhero
kids who are all disabled and they go to
a super hero High School and find
themselves in a special ed class it's
been decided that they're not able to
use their powers to the full extent due
to physical or mental disabilities main
characters Philip and he's blind but
he's also telekinetic so he'll struggle
to find ways to use his power since he
can't see the things he wants to try and
move the powers are all somewhat
restricted based on the disabilities
that are unique to each of them so the
stories about how they become friends
and band together and there's a mystery
that envelops the town and they find
themselves smack in the middle of it and
they start learning ways to use their
powers that none of them expected nobody
expected their struggle is about finding
and then claiming their proper place in
the
society what really got me interested in
the idea of this book at least to start
writing was the idea giving a character
some kind of super ability making them
superhuman in some way super powers but
then stripping some of it away and sort
of trying to examine what life might be
like right there in the middle between
being a full-on superhero and regular
old human I hope you guys have check it
out it's really I'm really excited to
hear you can pre-order the Able's right
now by going to the Able's book comm and
choosing your preferred vendor we will
also have an audiobook available for
pre-order soon narrated by who else meet
don't forget to send in confirmation of
your order so that we can add you to the
list and you don't miss any of our
updates or secrets ins videos just go to
the Able's book comm all the information
you need is there on a serious note
thanks for being fans of cinemasins
which is the only reason I'm finally
able to release a story that has lived
with me for more than 10 years also
before I forget waiting
[Music]
if you want more information don't worry
I'll be promoting this book through the
cinemasins channel to tell you more
about the story leading up to release
and oh by the way I will definitely be
sending this book or the movie version
or whatever they make of it version just
the book
[Music]